نشاهد معكم صور لانتشار الشرطه البرازيليه
في محيط مقر لانصار فول سونارو في
برازيليا فول سونارو وهو الرئيس السابق
هنا طبعا هذا الانتشار ياتي بعد اقتحامات
شهدتها المقرات الحكوميه الرئيسيه هناك في
برازيليا منها المحكمه العليا مقر
الكونجرس وايضا القصر الرئاسي طبعا هذه
اسفرت ايضا عن تحطيم نوافذ وتدمير اعمال
فنيه سرقه النسخه الاصليه لدستور البلاد
لعام 1988 وايضا تم الاستلاء على بنادق من
مكتب لامن الرئاسه بالتالي
اصبح هنا هناك انتشار امني همم كما نشاهد
همم لانه انصار سونار بداوا كما نشاهد همم
بنصب الخيام على ما يبدو لتجهيز لاحتجاجات
قادمه على ما يبدو من الصور التي
وعلى اثر ال- ال- الاقتحامات التي حدثت
بالامس مشاهدينا المحكمه العليا
البرازيليه اصدرت قرار بتجميد مهام حاكم
العاصمه البرازيليه روشا وذلك لمده ثلاثه
اشهر وتم اتهامه بركاب بارتكاب اخطاء
ساهمت في اقتحام المقر الحكوميه الثلاثه
التي ذكرتها قبل قليل
الاف المؤيدين للرئيس السابق بولسونارو
اذا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره للقوات
الامنيه المنتشره
المشاهدين في البرازيليه همم وذلك
استعدادا لمواجهه الاحتجاجات القادمه من
انصار بولس السونار والذين يقومون بنصب
الخيام في الشوارع استعدادا لهذه
الاحتجاجات تجمع مشاهدينا المئات المئات
من انصار والسونار مقابل المئات ايضا من
القوات الشرطه البرازيليه والجيش في
الشوارع الرئيسيه وامام كذلك المقال
الحكوميه الرئيسيه يحاولون فضل الاعتصام
وبسط الامن
ومنع عمليات التخريب التي طالت مبنى
المحكمه العليا مبنى الكونجرس مبنى القصر
الرئيسي كذلك واسفلت كما ذكرت عن تحطيم
النوافذ وتدمير اعمال فنيه وسرقه الكثير
من النسخه الاصليه او النسخه الاصليه
تحديدا لدستور البلاد لعام 1988
بالاضافه الى استيلاء على بنادق من مكتب
لامن الرئاسه اذا نشاهد مئات من افراد
الشرطه والجيش البرازيلي ينتشرون في
الشوارع وامام المقرات الحكوميه الرئيسيه
وامام الخيام التي تم نصبها من قبل مؤيدين
بولسونارو والذين يستعدون للقيام
باحتجاجات
ومعارضات كما يبدو لرئيس الحالي سنتابع
تفاصيل ما يحدث هناك معكم اتباعا